salamualikum' what I mentally better
care to brothers and sisters in defense
now you guys might be wondering what am
i doing in this forest well guys were
asking you guys to help me inshallah in
my course which is happening in Ghana
Brava who seemed his work of human
relief foundation he's been in Ghana and
a video that I'm gonna show you right
after this is very shocking and I urge
you guys to watch now the question you
also may be asking me is what is this
bottle of water in my hand that's quite
dirty it's quite muddy well this is the
cause that we're raising for because in
Ghana in this village people are
breaking their fast with literal water
dirty water that even as feces in it yes
you heard right has faeces in it and
when these people are drinking this
they're not saying they're not saying
this is disgusting they're saying
alhamdulillah this is how they're
breaking their fast with this water now
am I gonna drink this there is no way
I'm going to have drink this even though
it's a challenge and it defeats the
whole purpose of it I can't do it I
genuinely can't do you know why because
for my own safety I can't drink this not
knowing what's inside it or what it can
do to me these people don't have that
choice I have this choice to say you
know what I'm not gonna drink this these
people don't have that choice brothers
and sisters we all do not only just
water we have a choice to have eat what
we want when we want what dessert we're
gonna have after we are spoiled
brothers and sisters over asking us to
give this people this community
Christian or Muslim villages around the
area were fundraising 50 thousand pounds
and this is not just for one well this
is actually electronical devices that's
gonna help cleanse the water it's not a
well it's gonna electronically cleanse
the water and give them pure water to
drink and we'll lie every single human
being this
this the bare minimum to drink a clean
water all I'm asking you guys to watch
this video and help the cause at the
link and I'll challenge
Musa Batman and Faizal Chaudhary to the
challenge I couldn't do it could be
drink muddy water please
inshallah send the challenge them and
let's get this pop in and raise this
money
Oh just finishing off when we raise the
funds I will be traveling to Ghana with
Mohammadi job and Sheikh Mohammed and
will seem sorry I totally forgot we're
gonna be going there with a camera team
is whirling shava and we're going to
specifically for every single person
that donated specifically we're gonna go
to that village and make two hour with
them together mentioning every single
one of your name even if it's one pound
you get towards of course we're going to
collectively do it on fat on film record
it it's gonna be on my channel about
monthly after Ramadan inshallah
right now I'm speechless we've come to
this village and people have asked for
what other women have complained about
what they have to go through to get
water and on the days where it's not
possible the struggles that the children
go through and they brought me this look
at this mud this is mud I don't call
this water I couldn't believe it until
in this village this is normal
when I find that like I've speechless
they laugh at me like this is normal
alhamdulillah this is normal people say
they don't waste food people in the
world ain't got food don't waste water
these people with no war and it's just
another thing that you hear until you
see it for yourself
we're here we're ready to help we're
ready to serve
are you ready to join us are you ready
to make a difference